um so listen I want to start with
congratulations on the sequel uh you did
an amazing job with it uh
um did you actually feel because the
first film was so successful and Netflix
paid for two sequels and they paid a lot
of money did you feel a little pressure
or more pressure making the sequel like
this really has to be a good movie I
mean yeah but no more pressure than you
always feel when you do something new
like this has to be a good movie I think
uh I hope that's always there I mean I I
wrote the thing before we made the next
Netflix deal so I didn't know who we're
making it with when I when I wrote it so
that didn't come into play but um yeah I
don't know I I think it was to me that
the fact that the the mode of doing
another one as opposed to trying to
build off of or top the first one it was
about looking back to how Agatha
Christie did her novels where each one
was completely different it had its own
reason for being and I think that let me
just approach this one as its own movie
with its own goals and its own you know
everything so um I think maybe that
helped take some of the pressure off but
yeah I did definitely feel it a little
bit with all the films you've made which
shot or sequence is this a curveball
which shot or sequence ended up being
like the most challenging to pull off
whether it be camera moves whether it be
the dialogue and the camera move you
know it was just a real pain in the a
real pain in the butt I mean we've had
like difficult shots before but in terms
of
in terms of scenes I mean I feel like
maybe this isn't like the most difficult
but in the first knives out there's like
a sequence that starts the movie in in
the library with blanc's questioning all
of the suspects and it's a very
complicated scene where there's lots of
inner cutting of the different
questioning and you're setting up every
character trying to get the a lot of
information clear and I think that
sequence whatever it was eight ten
minutes we re-cut over and over for the
length of the editing process up until
the very end it was the last thing we
were working on still trying to trim it
down so there's any time you have a
complicated sequence like that that's a
that's something you always dig into I'm
curious with when you came up with the
idea for Glass Onion how much did you
debate this is the idea I want to go
with and because obviously you're making
another one after this but you know how
did you know this was the one I wanted
for the next movie and did you almost do
something else
I you know I there were a couple of
things I was kind of entertaining one of
them was kind of like a bigger more meta
even more Meadow wacky idea that um
which I won't pitch because in case I
want to use it down the line I want to
spoil it but
um no I don't know I think it you have
to kind of um
that was one thing that could be a
potential trap of these especially
thinking like oh my God how do I top the
last one I think you could probably get
in a cycle of thinking of rejecting each
idea is not like good enough
um because no idea is good enough until
you start working on it I think so I
kind of just picked a horse early on it
was like okay it'll be this and you
start going down the path and sculpting
it and then it turns into the thing and
it becomes what it is the reaction to
this film has been very strong and I'm
curious as a filmmaker does that I know
you I think you've said that you want to
go into making another knives out as
your next film does it energize you when
you have this kind of reaction and part
two to this is do you already have the
idea for the next one it energizes it
also is like your previous question it's
it's scary also because once you you
know when you're making something it's
like it's like a ball of mud that you're
forming you got your hands in there it's
personal it's it's your thing and then
the instant you put it out there
um kind of especially if people like it
it suddenly becomes this and we sit here
and do these interviews about it and
talk about it
um it suddenly becomes this thing
outside of yourself that's this kind of
gilded thing and you kind of forget how
you made it sort of so it makes it a
little scarier actually but in a good
way I mean um to do the next one I don't
have the idea for the next one I'm
starting right now to kind of think and
the big thing for me is just how can it
be totally different not just from the
first one but also from Glass Onion on
that note I have to stop but I'm sure
that we will talk again at some point
yes please